in every single one of us there is a
void that can never be filled a part of
us that yearns for a complete and
definitive understanding of the life
that engulfs us an omni essent endpoint
in the pursuit of knowledge we possess a
level of consciousness that seemingly
never meets the needs of the reality
that precedes it we are conscious enough
to observe the world ask questions and
make logical summations but we are not
conscious enough to find and sustain
conclusive overarching answers from it
all our most meaningful questions can
only be speculated questions like where
we came from why we are here where we
are going and what is the point of it
all the simple fact is we currently have
no way of finding answers to these
questions perhaps these answers do not
even exist in conclusive form or perhaps
humans are not made with the purpose to
ever find them when reflecting on our
inability to conclusively answer our
most basic existential questions over
the last several hundred thousand years
it begins to feel hopeless and it is our
continuing ignorance of reality that
creates the void that we can never quite
fill it is why we chase distractions and
temporary pleasures in life why we all
sometimes feel lost sad and helpless
because what is the point of living
without answers as to why we live at all
but arguably not having all of the
answers is the greatest reason to live
as humans we operate from a system of
duality that cares about logic and
understanding as well as emotion and
feeling our purpose and enjoyment of
life is not bound exclusively to a
finite endpoint of the pursuit of
knowledge it is also dependent on our
ability to feel the emotion of life's
fluctuation and uncertainty the
perpetual game of cat and mouse that we
play with reality is what gets us
excited and interested to be alive
without it what would there be to strive
for what would there be to be inspired
by the door for creating and searching
for unique meaning in life would close
we should not live with existential
angst or a constant chip on our shoulder
because we do not and cannot possess
definitive answers to all of our
questions instead we should live with
the excitement and Wonder that comes
from the fact that because of this we
will always possess the potential for
new discoveries and new worlds of life
we will always be able to create
theories and meaning and experience the
or of their realizations it is deeply
human to ask questions and work towards
understanding and explanations to
fantasize about the singularity between
humanity and the reality in which it
resides to visualize an end point of
intelligence and become synchronized
with absolute truth but it is also
deeply human to never achieve this and
to believe and depend on it occurring
misses the entire point
the pursuit of knowledge can and should
just exist for itself this pursuit is
what makes us who we are
excitement Wonder and humanity itself
are all rooted in the very fact that
life or at least our understanding of it
is constantly in flux and we can always
learn something new about it if we view
life in this way the void we all have
within us we'll begin to feel a little
less deep thank you for watching if we
found enjoyment and value in this video
please give it a thumbs up share your
thoughts in the comments below and if
you are not already be sure to subscribe
to our Channel
we are constantly coming out with new
videos to help you experience life with
clarity and Wonder